I love detectives I'm very much looking  forward to working with wait a second  you two are in love what that's  ridiculous  don't tell a tale to a tale teller it's  the oldest story in the world girl cop  gets by partner boy falls in love with  girl girl explodes and balls into a  year-long coma you couldn't be more  wrong you should stick to writing novels  miss Wilder you your story's written all  over your face poor family ran away with  the circus for a better life 11 long  hard years of riding the rails as a  strong man I bet you're still sending  money home to Romania ha kid no deeper  ah and you you are a lover a man of  passion and romance I see you dead in a  boating accident in 16 months